[Music]
the fortnite zero point is
reaching collapse johnsy's reality
hopping is causing cracks in the sphere
and something big
is about to happen with season six only
a matter of days away and with the zero
point
destabilizing fast i thought it was time
to look back at the journey of that
floating orb of power
after three years of live events and
in-game updates we can revisit each
moment
and see what all the fuss is about so
sit your butt down for 10 minutes use
cold adamarro if you'd be so kind to
support my nonsense and let's take a
walk
down memory lane
where were you on the 30th of june 2018
the day the first ever fortnite live
event happened
i remember getting in the game seconds
before the rocket launched
back then we had no idea this was
related to the zero points
agent johnsy would be harnessing in
chapter 2 season 6
but it sure was it's all connected as
the rocket fell to earth it was able to
open up rips
in the fabric of time over a year later
we saw one of those tears in the build
up to season x the rocket pinpointed the
exact location of the zero point
above loot lake before breaking time and
space once again
and leaving this reality behind the
visitor inside would prove to come back
but not just yet on to season five and
kevin
the roaming cube of death was somehow
attracted to the same spot the rocket
targeted the season before
we are still not entirely sure if these
events were linked and if kevin was
attempting to find the zero point
but after a visit to another dimension
the lake was removed
one less layer between us and the zero
point
symbolized by this rainbow the remnants
of the cube
sat in a stonehenge formation but still
no zero point just yet
season eight of chapter one arrived and
we saw a mysterious government agency
construct
dig sites around the og island it's only
now two years later that we've made the
link between those shadowy individuals
and the i o agency
plaguing us in chapter 2. finally they
found the vault
exactly where the rocket foretold and
exactly where kevin committed sudoku
the inhabitants of the island completed
tasks to unlock the vault
and finally the day arrived the vault
opened
and everything changed forever
[Music]
there it is the zero point the nexus of
power
hidden under the island since 2018 while
most people were
preoccupied by the unvaulting of the
drum gun some of us
looked for clues a desk and a mask
someone was here protecting the zero
point but before we arrived
she had already left this event also saw
a volcano explode and shatter a portion
of polar peak
little did we know this was also related
to the zero point
[Music]
season nine of fortnite saw the biggest
shift in time we'd ever seen
with the entire island brought forward
into the future
the volcano was now a disused quarry and
the zero point vault was being harnessed
for its unlimited power
neo tilted rose up and the mysterious
individual from the vault
now had a statue things were going
pretty well on the island
the zero point was safe but the cracks
in polar peak revealed a new enemy
your mum who quickly vanished into the
sea around the island
we met bunker jonesy this season a
snapshot of agent jonesy in years to
come who had visions of the future
bunker jonesy told us to expect an epic
battle for the zero point between a
monster
and a mech armed with this information
we believe singularity began to
work on a mech until that day came the
polar peak monster
left the ocean and just as johnsy
foretold made a run for the vault
attempting to break it open the mech
sprang into life
and the best live event in my opinion
ensued on the cusp of losing the fight
mecca did something we can never forget
deliberately opening the vault and
claiming the power from that zero point
cracking it in the process the influx of
power allowed mecca to banish the
monster
using a sword disguised as singularity
statue
in the heart of tilted the island was
saved
but at what cost the exposed nexus
continued to crack
until season x arrived
the zero point exploded
[Music]
back in august 2019 the island was
plunged into perpetual stasis
suspended in reality the meteorite held
in midair and most importantly
the zero point we just saw explode is
paused at that exact moment
this led to a new zero point phenomenon
rift beacons
by using the energy from the zero point
the new visitor
aka the scientist built these
monstrosities
they acted like portals to other worlds
but it's way more than that
they brought the other worlds here that
zero point is packed with energy
this function also changed time
reverting retail roll back to the og one
even gotham city appeared this season
was way better than most people realized
at the time
as the season ended the scientists
rebuilt the rocket from the very first
event
and on the last day of season x and the
last day of chapter one
the seven realized their intentions and
destroyed the loop we found ourselves in
by collapsing the zero point
[Music]
the end arrived sucked into a black hole
never to see light again
the zero point destroyed forever but
then
chapter two began
[Music]
somehow the island was rebuilt was it
the zero point rebuilding its own
reality
or maybe an external force we're a long
way from answers there
but one season later the zero point was
discovered once again
just like last time it's buried deep
beneath the island but unlike last time
a different man knew about its existence
midas
a being of immense power who like the
fable you've probably heard
could turn anything into gold as the
season went on midas built an
underground facility
under the agency and in private he made
a device
to harness its power the biggest
question i had back then
was about the zero point was it always
there under the agency
or did midas manufacture a new zero
point
using the storm maybe i'm overthinking
this after a long season he switched on
the device
[Music]
midas device looks to use the zero point
power to push back the storm
and for a moment it actually worked but
not for long enough
a tsunami destroyed his escape attempts
and the loop
returned the zero point device falling
back into obscurity under the island
there was a very important side effect
that day somehow
we did escape the loop but only for a
few seconds
appearing in the office of agent johnsy
who spoke to us in person
before we were dragged back to the
island and the loop
two months later one of the strangest
things happened once again due to the
zero point
[Music]
somehow through the fabric of space
galactus from the marvel universe
felt the power of the zero point and
raced to the island
he hungered to consume that power
luckily his herald
happened to be thor the god of thunder
no less
over the course of season four tony
stark and the avengers prepared for
galactus attack
if the zero point was taken the island
would perish including everyone upon it
to cut a long story short galactus
arrived he went snorkeling for some
reason off the coast
until he hungered so bad he made his
move
i hunger
galactus reached for the zero point
uncovering it once more
for a brief moment we see the zero point
fight back before being totally
overpowered
of course iron man had a plan and we
saved the zero point
using laser cannons ac dc music and
wolverine
as over a billion battle buses were
consumed the battle was
over galactus was portaled away but that
was not the end
back in the real world agent johnsy was
suddenly awoken
mid earthquake this confirms the zero
point is affecting both worlds and
destabilizing all realities
which brings us to season five of
chapter two agent jones is sent
back onto the fortnite island to
stabilize the zero point
and prevent anyone from escaping but
he misses a valuable piece of
information and do not draw the
attention of the seven
jones don't get the attention of the
seven
you know the guys who first mark the
zero point location and the guys who
sent us into a black hole
i'm still not sure if they're the good
guys you know i also think the seven are
responsible for defeating the 400 foot
monster too
but that isn't proven just yet so let's
move on on the island
agent jones uses a shard from the zero
point to move around between different
timelines and realities
his plan is to recruit the greatest
hunters and fighters in history
to quash any attempts to run by
potential escapees but here lies the
problem
every time jonesy uses the zero point
power to find another hunter
he destabilizes the zero point further
more cracks appear on the sphere
as more tears in time appear around the
map
the rift locations now are beginning to
fall apart and the zero point
does not look happy at all as season
five closes
this issue will get worse every single
day
as a side note have you noticed that
jonesy using the power of the zero point
has made himself one of the most feared
hunters in town
just look at him as he meets ripley he
has the tattoo of snake eyes the crest
of the mandalorian
the gauntlet inspired by the predator or
maybe maeve
ryu's headband okay that's likely his
tie to be honest
trying to look like vazquez from the
aliens movie but still worth a mention
and look daryl's arrows from the walking
dead are on his thigh
johnsy also now has the power of
ripley's cat
that may not be important but i thought
it was worth referencing
as i'm saying this there's around 10
days before season six begins
and the zero point remains the main
narrative of the entire fortnight saga
will batman and the dc world be called
into action by the zero point
will agent john d continue summoning
characters from other worlds
will the zero point fight back and take
us back to the original island
we'll find out soon enough that's the
story so far of the fortnite zero point
thanks very much for watching i really
appreciate it please think about using
code adamaru if you're still here at
this point like these legends on screen
right now
thanks again i'll see you next time bye
[Music]
you